- What about personally,
what plans do you have
for the holidays other
than watching the movie?
- (laughs) I'm definitely
gonna watch the movie
and then, you know, I'm
gonna be honest with you,
this year I was, I have dreaded
this year more than anything
since my divorce, because
this was gonna be the year
that I didn't have my
kids Christmas morning.
But I've never looked forward
to a day more now than ever.
I now, I'm gonna get my kids
on Christmas day at noon
and Santa is gonna
actually come the next day,
so we're gonna celebrate
Christmas the next day
so I don't miss out on, you know,
their little feet pitter-patterning,
coming down and seeing
the presents from Santa.
So I'm excited to create
our own memory this year
and I'm really looking forward to that.
(audience claps)
- Oh, that's awesome.
I'm so glad that worked out right there.